-Hey, so, Hank, this is crazy.
But you have been now doin
32 years of "The Simpsons.
You were a young man
when "The Simpsons" began.
What was it -- Did you have an
sense of what it would be --
I mean, certainly,
no one would've had a sens
of how long it would've gone on.
But what was it like
at the beginning
when you went in
to record voices?
-You're talking 33,
34 years ago.
I was 22 or 23 years old.
It was an audition
like any other.
I kind of strolled in.
Matt Groening and the late great
Sam Simon were sitting there
Jim Brooks wasn't there,
but the other two co-creators.
And I didn't know --
No one knew what the show was.
It was a year or two
before it got released.
And the first voice
I auditioned was Moe.
[ As Al Pacino ] And I was doing
a sort of Pacino impression.
A young, kind of "Dog Day
Afternoon" Al Pacino impressio
I thought might be good for me
[ Normal voice ]
And they were like,
"Can you make that gravelly?
[ As Moe ] And so I kind o
made it gravelly.
And that sounded like Moe.
[ Normal voice ] And they said
"Cool. Will you come record?
I'm like, "Now?
Like, right now?"
They were like, "Yeah."
And I walked over with the
on the Fox lot.
Like, I'm 22.
I don't know what's going on
in general anywhere,
let alone in this circumstance
I recorded --
-That's crazy.
-Yeah, and then every week
they had me back,
and then the show didn't air
for like another year or two
after that.
-This might be
an ignorant question.
But do you always see
the art of the character
before you come up with a voice?
-Never.
-Wow.
-Sometimes in certain
animation projects,
they'll kind of show you
what they're thinking.
But in this case, no.
I had no idea what anythin
would look like.
I just did voices.
And they were very meticulous,
which I realized --
I didn't know then 'cause I ha
nothing to compare it to,
but they were very painstaking
about takes
and trying it this way,
trying it that way.
So it was a lot -- In the firs
year or two of the show,
we were there a long time
recording.
Now it's kind of like clockwork,
as you might imagine.
-Sure, yeah.
Did you --
So your son's 11.
Growing up when you were,
you know, reading books to him
and being a father in general,
was he impressed
with your ability
to come up with voices
and be a mimic?
-No. He was, if anything,
frightened and annoyed.
Like, "Why are strange noise
coming out of Daddy?
It doesn't make any sense.
And when we were pregnant,
we ran into Robin Williams
who I knew and worked with
a few times.
And, of course, Robin bein
Robin did a 20-minute schtic
on my wife's pregnant belly.
And in between crazy jokes
said, "You'll see" --
'cause he knew
I was a voice guy.
He said, "You'll see.
Your kid won't let you do voices
for like the first six years
he's alive."
And he was completely correc
about that.
And then over the years,
he has eased his policy.
But then it had to be, like --
Certain voices would scare him
and still do.
Like, I can do a pretty good
villain, you know.
[ Gravelly voice ] I can start
with this stuff.
You know, and [Growls]
[ Normal voice ] And he's like
"Ah, Daddy, no, no!"
-[ Laughs ]
My son will be saved from that
by my terrible voice work.
Hey, last thing.
This is a real --
I want to shout you out.
The Brockmire jacket,
which is a worthy inclusion,
is currently in the Hall o
Fame, Baseball Hall of Fame.
-It is.
Next to the "Simpsons" display
for the "Homer at the Bat"
episode
is the Brockmire jacket
and old-timey microphone.
I think the folks over there
are big "Brockmire" fans.
I'm very bad at selling
my own projects.
But I love this show so much
"Brockmire," I mean.
I love "The Simpsons," too
Take the "Brockmire" challenge
Seth Meyers' audience.
It's all on Hulu,
all four seasons.
You can binge it now.
It's eight episodes per season
22 minutes.
That's one quarantine afternoon.
I mean, come on.
-Absolutely.
-Watch the first five minute
of Season 1.
If you don't --
of Episode 1, Season 1.
If you don't laugh, you have
my permission to stop watching
-And I also want to stress
because I think
my new favorite thing
is if you can have
a 22-minute show
that also has some drama in it
that's a gold mine for me.
And "Brockmire"
has a lot of that.
So, I highly recommend it,
as well.
Hank, it's always a pleasure
to see you, buddy.
-Thank you very much,
Seth Meyers.
Keep up the wonderful work
-[ Laughs ]